what's the job of an artist
make people feel that's like the
simplest
so if you're a musician um
composer whatever like your job is to
make people to amplify whatever people
are feeling
to amplify it that's it so you read a
good book to escape to make them feel
safe or anchored you know to something
that
if their life is chaotic your job is to
um
to my job as a photographer if i'm
taking pictures just
to show people the beauty and something
that they cannot see
you know um you're a cinematographer
make them
feel something and that's what your job
is
do you remember the first picture first
still image that you saw
that made you feel something it could
have even been an ad you know there's
some ads that are
fantastic like you look at them and it's
herbert's
just knock my socks off there's
something about and i didn't know why i
liked him
but i i loved his work
so much that even before i even knew how
to pick up a camera
i knew that name but because i was so
obsessed with herbert's work i saw some
of the influence of course seep into my
my work and so because of that i also
stopped
studying other photographers i actually
put a ban
on now i can because now i think i have
a definitive style
you know but in the beginning i was like
oh geez i don't even subconsciously pick
up
their style because then i'll you know
start mimicking them
so i just kept shooting and shooting and
shooting but
um but i think the her brits series
he did everything from for naomi
campbell and michael jackson and madonna
and these just amazing
shapes that he did so her brits i don't
remember the exact picture though
do you think that that's something that
new photographers should be
wary of or oh you do okay so you see
them emulating
yeah you see them copying
and they maybe don't even realize
they're copying i think they realize
that i think that there's
a photographer and then there's somebody
that wants insta
fame and i put them in two different
categories like when you look on the
explore page of instagram
i swear to god if i see one more colored
smoke photoshoot
it's not original it wasn't original
like maybe like
several years ago when someone did the
first one that was cool it's not
original
and i see people doing it with the same
face mask i know that's offensive to
some viewers but it's like i just see
people
copying for the sake of likes and and
validation
and not for the sake of making a picture
if i see one more pair of feet
dangling from the top of a building
looking down unoriginal boring
you know so i think that i i don't think
the photographer should
you know if you don't want to study
another photographer
i think just no actually my advice for
photographers would be
don't study just create because what
they're doing is they're studying the
explore page
on instagram and they're seeing it and
you see one tacky picture you get
another one you get another one the
algorithm
you know so i think just just go out
there and just create
and that's what i always tell
photographers that now i mentor and i
say
just for six months just shoot shoot
shoot and then start seeing
the similarities between shoots and
you're like oh
so i really like high contrast i really
really like saturated colors you know
and then start diving more into that but
man i answer questions you don't even
ask so because i just realized i didn't
answer that question
well i'm just thinking about no no
that's fine i'm just thinking about
let's say for me being
a child of the 80s and looking through
vogue magazine
and it wasn't just really cool clothes
but these photographers created a world
sometimes it was completely messy and
chaotic and then the outfit was very
simple
and just there wasn't that much to
really look now it's so overwhelming
do you think that's almost a detriment
yeah i think it is a detriment
i think that photographers or any
artists the ones that rise to the top
are the ones that add
depth and that's how i see the future of
social media
add depth to their pictures and
so i'm again i'm kind of answering a
question but i'm not
there's i always tell people don't
clutter the internet
don't take a picture just because take a
picture because it has a meaning for you
but don't litter the internet you know
with just
mediocre stuff um
even if the lighting on it is terrible
but if the the meaning behind it was
important that's not littering that's
like
you know good so i think that it's
there's
the only thing that makes people stop
and look at a picture is if it has some
kind of depth
so yeah i think it's i think it's hard
for photographers nowadays you're
competing against
everybody has a camera in their hand
again i didn't answer your question well
that's okay because if you if you're
something yeah you want to expand on pl
feel free i mean i'm just throwing out
some like really simple questions but
you know you think back to like those
depression dust bowl photos that
that yeah have lived on there were so
few people at that time
do you know and now to go and let's say
take pictures of the great recession
which people had or the malls of america
yeah yeah that had been
declining yeah that that was but at that
time there weren't really that many
even though they're fascinating to see
takes you into the world of the 80s and
and these like failed malls but i'm not
even sure where i'm going with the
question i guess
it's just because there's so much to
look at now
is the meaning behind all of them just
it's not as strong
i think that there were a lot of
photographers even in the 80s we just
didn't see their pictures
people are still developing rolls of
film and they were just hidden in a box
somewhere
now it's just everybody is screaming
look at me look at me
you know so i think that the the same
ratio of good work and bad work is still
out there
people are always like taking pictures
you know 12 year old
24 36 and and you just didn't see them
yeah so i i don't think that that has
changed much
can people take a tasteful selfie
god i don't know why i have such an
allergy to selfies
um is it the intention behind it it's
look at me
and you don't know how much strength it
takes for me to like not type
you look just like your other 15 selfies
you know
yeah you could take it uh i don't know
i don't i don't know i don't um
it's an interesting science behind why
somebody would want a selfie
because would you i don't necessarily
want a photo of myself
sitting on a couch all messy
watching tv but some people are fine
with that
even though everybody does that are they
or do they feel they have to do it
to be accepted yeah i guess that's why
i'm confused i'm fascinated by people
that want
some people can do some really cool
stuff on instagram where they do take
photos of themselves
but they're in fun situations and
they're telling a story
yeah and i love it and i love seeing
them on vacation or whatever
but then there's the ones that it's just
it's literally it's like they woke up in
the morning and they just want to show
everybody
yeah i think so to answer your question
yes you could take a good selfie
or a what was your exact wording a
thoughtful or no or
one that's i guess tasteful tasteful yes
i think that if you are i okay so the
reason why i don't like selfies is
is this showing off look at me look at
the
car emblem that's accidentally perfectly
in frame
you know look at um the business class
ticket that's sticking out conveniently
enough out of my passport you know what
i'm saying
so when you're showing off i just think
it's tasteless and actually i kind of
unfollow now
um yeah i'm very i'm very mindful of
what goes in
in my brain pretty much so i think that
if you're on vacation alone
you see something amazing you're holding
your baby and there's
i don't know they look really adorable
and you want to take a picture because
you're proud
then i'm okay with that and who's to say
i set the rules on it but i'm just
saying personally then i'm okay with it
if you're showing off to make the viewer
feel
less even subconsciously less i i don't
deal well with that
it's kind of like they're saying how do
you know somebody's really rich is when
they go on a private jet and they don't
take a picture
you know it's just showing off okay
right we all know
it was jet x-jet or what or whatever
that
uber of jets is you know what i mean but
it's like at the showing off the
the the showing your nails off but you
want to make sure that mercedes-benz
emblem is shown
between the two fingers it's that kind
of culture that i dislike
what do you think the difference was
with let's say cindy sherman
and all of her photos which are so
fascinating to look at and i'm not
turned off by them
versus pretty people showing pictures
of themselves on instagram so because i
don't
really study other photographers i'm
ignorant to who cindy sherman is
oh okay okay she was oh and people are
going to correct me on this sorry
i think she'll probably brag on me first
for not knowing her oh okay
she she did a lot of interesting self
photos i could think she was in new york
city in like
the 80s and some of them aren't totally
pretty in there and there's like sort of
like
street photos but i think she you know
she wanted to sort of expose street life
in new york city and herself and how
as a woman walking down the street she
felt
and some of the stereo you know that's
interesting it was interesting and she
had a statement behind it
yeah um and so when i see that and
there's the nostalgia of
the the 80s or whatever late 70s forgive
me if the timeline is wrong
but then today where
someone doing a yoga pose with perfectly
straight hair
you know i get it it's a hustle if
you're if you're if you've got a
sponsored post
so be it it's going to get in your way
uh that's different advertising
i think for me it's just the intention
of why you take a picture whether
it's a selfie or pointing out
you know it's just
it's the intention are you trying to
make the viewer are you trying to
enlighten the viewer and
and add value to their life or are you
saying look at me look at me
look at the car i got look at the the
purse i have
look at me i'm in business class if
you're excited you got business class
because you got bumped up
be honest about it be like yo
like i can't believe you know
yeah i think that's what it is it's the
intention
okay i'm gonna get so much hate for that
but whatever
no i think we've reached the saturation
point with i think in the beginning it
was pretty cool and again there i see
some people that do it and they do some
really fun photos and they're not
creative sure they're they and they're
doing a story and then they tell
where they were and it's not all look at
them it's yeah this is what happened and
and i'm living yeah this cool little
adventure through their thing
and and i think that people will rip me
on this because like well he's got his
own youtube channel and he's filming
stuff sometimes too
so yeah whether it's a video form of a
selfie or whatever
i'd like to think that i'm adding value
to somebody's life and helping them
with their career a little bit you did a
cool one on going to the carolinas
yeah and i don't think you did it in a
way that was look at me it was kind of
like taking this road trip i was by
myself as a loner
right and you met this guy and so there
was the way you did it
wasn't like that it was about an
experience and you met this guy that i
think talked about you know live your
life now don't don't wait till when
you're older things like that
so there was a there was a purpose yeah
that was interesting i broke
into i break into a lot of places like
not people's homes but like
um i always i'm like it's just a sign
that says no trespassing how serious are
they
you know and um i broke into this
private lake area
and i'm just walking around i'm like let
me just get some b-roll for
maybe i'll do a youtube channel i don't
know and
there was a gentleman on the other side
of this little tiny pier
and i don't know if i heard him first or
if he heard me
but he started giving me life lessons
and he told me he's like you were meant
to be here today and it was the weirdest
thing
it was beautiful so i put him in that
video and that was it so that he just
he he gave me some deep life lessons and
he kept saying he's like you were
supposed to be here today
it's just really eerie now i think about
it but nice guy
yeah that was a cool video thanks
you have a lot of that that happens
don't you were these like these
synchronicities or these
maybe i look for it maybe i don't deny
it i don't know
i think a lot of creative people do that
you know i think you're right
yeah so we're just we're trained not to
be so
skeptical do you think it's because
we're open more open
yeah hell yeah and they're not like
looking at the watch no i think artists
are the purest people on earth
i do i think whether you write or you
sing or
you dance no you're the purest person i
just do that's why i get so angry when
people
take advantage of artists and they see
the beauty in things
and how do you think artists contribute
to being
taken advantage of they work for free
they work for exposure without a plan
you know they undercut each other
is that the term undercut yeah like the
uh photographers in general there's this
fight to the bottom of the barrel
you know so that's how they they don't
help each other
if you know something say something
so if you see i'm that guy if i walk
into sami's camera and someone's i'm
like hey
i have that tripod it's not that good
but if you i
just share say something you know
if i go rent a studio in downtown l.a
and
i've done it before or i'm like like i
literally see something but
not if i disagree with their lighting
but i know that this person's
brand new just newly hatched
photographer
i'll ask i'm like would you be open to
something because i see you trying to do
something
i'm nosy i like look you know whatever
but
say something help them do you think
that's harder to do here because i like
if i see i saw a woman and her kids
crossing the street and a car was coming
and i said
oh look out or whatever and she looked
at me like i was insane but the car
almost hit them
and luckily the little boy saw me and he
turned around
and they went but i find it when you
talk to people in l.a they
don't talk to me yeah it's a city of um
pretend to be unbothered pretend to be
cool pretend to not be
fame struck or you know prestige struck
or whatever
i get fame struck in a sense of like wow
you could shoot with anybody
but you choose me i'm a little bit fame
struck in that like wow thank you
for that right um or we're in the same
spot and you've been on all these
platforms and whatever so i think that
people act too
cool and they have this unbothered
or on board attitude like watch watch
your la parties and they'll be like ah i
have to go to this party and i don't
want to i'm like yeah you do
you totally want to go and that's what
you're telling me
that the person's first name and last
name you know
but i think that um
do i think the people now yeah they just
don't i i don't know i don't think that
i don't know i just know about myself so
if i see a photographer and i see him
trying to hold a reflector and take a
picture
i'll straight up ask him like let me
hold your reflector i won't tell him i'm
a photographer and they're like are you
serious i'm like i don't mind
and i just hold like i like to help
people and you say the artist or
photographer should take the long way
home
and look at ali always just go to drives
go rent a scooter and just go find stuff
take pictures and you know and go i
i love that door because when you i'm so
glad you pointed that out um
like when somebody like right now i'm
building a deck for an artist for a
record cover shoot
and he wants something fashiony but a
little bit different
i want to go through my pictures that i
took and go okay this was in
lincoln heights this was in highland
park this is in orange county
and you know so you're cataloging
because
when you look at pictures in downtown
los angeles i'm like we all know that's
hill street
we all know that's broadway so when you
find the unique place
it's cool you know not angels i mean
nothing against angels flight but
there's
so you look at certain things it's it's
more fun that way
yeah and sometimes you get in trouble
but whatever
oh because then people chase you out of
places yeah
yeah yeah and what do you say when that
happens
sorry so you sort of like what is it
i'm not gonna call someone like if i
trust that like if i got caught in that
north carolina lake
area i'm not going to look at you and go
act dumb i'm like i'm sorry and i just
like i'm a jerk and i just sleep
you know i'm not going to be insulting
to you so you just own it and
just go own it and go sorry i'm sorry
i'm a jerk you know try to use charm
i'm not that charming so it's like you
know just go sorry
and just leave when you went there
to film did people react to you
differently with the camera than maybe
in l.a
were they more excited to be so i didn't
go to film
i i went to um
i went to go visit a couple of friends
and i went
through i tried to go on trips alone
every so often and just just go see new
things
so i went to south carolina not a lot to
see there beautiful but
you know i started in ache in south
carolina and then i went to north
carolina and then i flew back home
so i'll go do things i'll go um
take meetings i'll go introduce myself
to somebody i'll
i always dm every like
i reach out to three people every single
day so i've made a lot of friends that
way
i always d i'm a photographer i'm like
you showed up on my explore page or you
somehow you came across my screen and i
just saw your pictures and i'm like
congrats dude and you know they're
tripped out a little bit because people
aren't that
forward with it but i just you make
friends you don't know i don't know how
i'm going to meet it's fun
so that's one of your things you like to
learn something new every day every
single day
to three people every single day
if i don't learn something new so
i've been a little bit lazy within the
past 12 months okay
but when business is really booming i
can flip back through my
uh i just go to like staples and i i
have
i designed my own day to that i don't
know if that made it sound so i designed
my own daily planner
because like there's a lot of really
great planners but there will always be
a section that i won't use
okay and um so i just decided i'm gonna
take what i use
i'm going to design it to what works for
me and i design my own daily planner
and then i go and i make multiple copies
and i spiral bound it and i use that
every day
then i use every inch of that paper and
so in that is
i have to reach out to three people
every single day
and they're not necessarily asking for a
job
like i try to i try to split them
because
i'm behind the camera or i'm in a room
somewhere at a table head down working
planning a shoot
or i'm behind a computer screen people
don't even know i exist
so if i know that somebody
put up a post and says um they don't
even have to be in the industry
you know it's about building your
community they could say everybody pray
for my father he's in the hospital again
i will go and i'll say how is your dad
doing
et cetera et cetera i'll reach out to
them i
but i try to split it to one personal
one congratulate somebody for doing
something amazing
and one let somebody know that i exist
in the embed
in in the event that it turns into a job
later on
and it adds up fast because when i don't
do it how many people a day do we reach
out to
not really but you're like 15 in a week
well you could see the amazon delivery
guy yeah
yeah exactly yeah sure he's not exactly
yeah i'm sure they're very nice
you know and so i just reach out to
people and i congratulate people on
their work and
and all that and i learned one new thing
every day
whether it's about lighting or a camera
or a tax code
or a marketing tip or seo or whatever
you